dans sa culotte des barricades à chasser
chose est sûre le plan d'action
suffirait que j'ai un fantasme en ce
moment c'est quoi je vous jure que c'est
la vérité
j'aimerais avoir une aventure sexuelle
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez un fantasme alors
j'en ai un
oui mais dur on peut tout dire vraiment
reste on reste correct we stay corrected
j'aimerais bien essayer avec beaucoup de
monde une partie je n'ai jamais fait ça
avec beaucoup de monde
bal à la fête de la bière entrés dans un
appartement et il ya plein de personnes
et ont fait que ça non j'ai d'accord à
une orgie c'est plus joli ça va bien
c'est nrj nrj avec ses plus jolis la
raison quand même énorme il n'a pas de
chantage je suis très inquiet surnommé
votation pour moi et je vous le dis je
comprends et samory choquer mais en même
temps c'est la patte fantasmes et
participe à la partouze de mature faire
sans un lift à voler dans un magasin de
meubles bas sera carreau après parce que
l on va mettre moins de 12 mois mon
fantasme et que chaque rapport sexuel
fasse perdre un kilo je connais plein
femme qui serait beaucoup plus ardentes
aux listes si c'était le cas tout mince
jean michel maire je vous demande pas
d'aller déjà réalisé quelques uns ont
même fait d'être invisible et pouvoir me
glisser dans des endroits il se passe
des choses sans qu'on le voit il pouvoir
regarder consentent à d'accord voilà et
vous thierry faire l'amour avec deux
jolies femmes pas à 59,1 pas beaucoup de
monde 2 je livre sur l'amour is gré pas
de jolies femmes qui ont désiré autant
dire 0%
là on part de loin des robes à jouer au
loto c'est beau
[Rires]
valladolid où beaucoup de gens ce gros
alors franchement j'ai beaucoup de
fantasmes j'ai nommé alors elles sont
aimées non mais elle est chaude
nationalité l'imagination c'est parce
que vous êtes à ramatuelle centre
gouffre c'est un truc qui passent même
devant elle car tu perds 3 kg tellement
chaud
non mais sans déconner dans sa culotte
le plateau est un travail d'imagination
mais c'est vrai que j'ai un fantasme en
ce moment c'est quoi je vous jure que
fait la vérité j'aimerais avoir une
aventure sexuelle avec jean michel mr là
là si je peux me permettre de le dire on
est dans l'île pour savoir si tout ce
qu'il nous dit est vrai et si vraiment
le gars est un bon coup mais un fanta
sait quelque chose
la bâtarde moi c'est ici tu m'appelles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]